Guten Tag. Ich bin Nuran Afji. Ich bin die Dienstabende in dieser Notaufnahme.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Sehr gerne. Können wir gerne machen.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich ganz schnell ein paar allgemeine Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Dieter Vogel.
Wie der Vogel?
Ja, wie ein Vogel.
Herr Vogel, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
54 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 6.08.1968.
Und wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 groß und wiege 80 Kilo.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß.
85 Kilo.
Und sind Sie bereitet?
Ja, ich habe eine Partnerin.
Sie sind nicht bereitet.
Wir leben zusammen.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite in einer Fabrik als Maschinenführer.
Ich bediene Maschinen in einer großen Fabrik.
Okay, Maschineningenieur.
Ich bin ein normaler Mitarbeiter in einer Maschinen.
Ich bediene Maschinen, ich arbeite in einer Produktion.
Also mein Beruf ist Maschinenführer.
Maschinenführer, okay.
Und wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Der Name?
Ja, bei wen sind Sie in Hausarzt-Behung?
Dr. Schmidt.
Genau, Herr Dr. Schmidt.
Mit DT oder?
Mit DT, richtig.
Was führt es Ihnen?
Also ich habe seit knapp 4 Stunden sehr starke Bauchschmerzen.
Wo genau tut es Ihnen weh?
Kontinuze bitte.
Also das ist eher hier im Oberbau.
Das ist Oberbau, das ist genau.
Oberbau, mittels oder linksseitig?
Ziemlich in der Mitte.
Also ziemlich in der Mitte.
Aber es ist auch beidseitig, manchmal ist variiert so ein bisschen.
Okay, seit 4 Stunden.
Und sind diese Schmerzen langsam oder plöselig aufgetreten?
Ganz plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und die werden auch immer stärker, muss ich sagen.
Die haben so langsam angefangen, stark.
Jetzt wären sie immer stärker.
Immer stärker.
Gibt es irgendwelche Auslöse?
Ist Ihnen etwas aufgefallen?
Ich bin nicht gefallen, ich habe nicht anders gegessen, als ich sonst esse.
Es ist plötzlich aufgetreten.
Plötzlich aufgetreten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz?
Kalapon 1 bis 10, wenn ein sehr leichter Schmerz ist,
10 unerträglicher Schmerzen.
Also ich würde sagen, es sind 7 schon.
Deswegen bin ich nicht mehr aufgetreten.
Herr Kogel, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Oder soll ich Ihnen Schmerz tablette geben?
Also wenn es schnell geht, dann halte ich das aus.
Aber ich habe schon eben zu Hause eine Ibe-Profen genommen.
Hat das Ihnen geholfen?
Das hat nicht wirklich geholfen, nein.
Okay.
Nach der Ibe-Profen Einnahme sind die Schmerzen sich verschlechter?
Gar keine Veränderungen.
Es hätte überhaupt nicht geholfen.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher stechend drückend?
Also beides, stechend und drückend.
Hatten Sie früher ähnliche Schmerzen?
In dieser Form noch nie.
Ich habe das manchmal gehabt, das kam und ging.
Aber in dieser Form habe ich das noch nie gehabt, tatsächlich.
Zum ersten Mal, okay.
Also es kam und ging.
Ich habe das früher in leichter Version, glaube ich, gehabt,
aber ich fand noch nie deswegen beim Arzt.
Also, ich habe das früher, also meine sehr richtig verstanden,
aber hatte sie früher ab uns, aber leichter Schmerzen.
Ganz genau.
Deswegen war ich auch nie beim Arzt.
Aber diesmal ist es extrem und deswegen bin ich im Krankenhaus
und ich hoffe, dass sie mir helfen können.
Schmerzen, irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, ich sage ja, also es ist eher so im Mittag,
aber es strahlt schon manchmal an beide Seiten,
nach links und rechts aus entlang der Rippen, aber auch nicht immer.
Das wird halt, ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen Übelkeit
und die Schmerzen werden dann stärker aktuell.
Okay.
Sie haben auch Übelkeit.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Ja, aber es kann jederzeit passieren.
Okay.
Wann haben Sie zum letzten Mal etwas gegessen?
Heute Morgen habe ich gefürchtigt, so gegen 10 Uhr.
Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliche?
Nein, immer das gleiche Kaffee, den Brotaufschnitt,
Wurst, Käse, Marmelade, das übliche.
Gibt es etwas, das nicht mehr schmerzt oder verstärkt?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie sich vorne holen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Und haben Sie auch Fieber?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Oder Schüttelbrot, nach Schweiß?
Nach Schweiß weiß ich nicht, ich habe das erst seit 4 Stunden.
Ich habe noch nicht geschlafen.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Aktuell nicht, ich habe Übelkeit.
Aktuell habe ich gar keinen Appetit.
Haben Sie auch Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, vielleicht ein bisschen, weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Es ist schon sehr stark nicht mehr.
Ja, jetzt ist es nicht.
Aktuell nicht, nein.
Haben Sie auch Püren?
Manchmal, nicht immer, manchmal.
Und haben Sie unterfülle Gefühle?
Ein bisschen, ja, tatsächlich seit heute habe ich ein bisschen Fülle gefühlt.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ich habe noch keinen Stuhlgang gehabt, und habe keine Probleme gehabt.
Seit wann konnten Sie keinen Stuhlgang?
Gestern war alles okay.
Seit heute?
Ich habe noch nicht das Bedürfnis gehabt.
Normalerweise gehen Sie regelmäßig auf die Toilette.
Richtig, richtig.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nicht wirklich, nein.
Normalerweise haben Sie Probleme beim Durch- oder Einschlafen?
Nein, habe ich normalerweise nicht.
Pülen Sie sich jetzt erschöpft oder kraftlos?
Nein, ich habe nur stark geschmerzen.
Es wäre vielleicht gut, wenn Sie mir etwas geben würden.
Ich habe jetzt wirklich sehr stark geschmerzen.
Ich würde mich gerne hinlegen.
Sie können sich hinlegen, Herr Vogel.
Herr Vogel, ich muss noch mal eine Frage stellen.
Ich habe nur ein paar Minuten gestartet.
Ich werde mit Ihrem Schmerz beschöpft.
Gibt es irgendwann eine Erkrankung bei Ihnen?
Ich habe hohe Cholesterinwerte, sagt mein Hausarzt.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Schon seit zwei Jahren, sagt er mir.
Leiden Sie an Herzkrankheiten?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Blindam wurde entfernt vor Jahren.
Ich habe eine Knieoperation gehabt.
Herr Vogel, nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich habe keine Medikamente, aber ich habe vor ein paar Monaten
das Schachtel nicht mehr, die Packung war zu Ende.
Ich habe etwas gegen Cholesterin genommen.
Gegen meine Fettwerte.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf irgendwelche Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe keine Medikamente.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Was meinen Sie?
Corona?
Ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Gegen Ketanus, weiß ich nicht mehr, wann das war.
Mein Hausarzt hat das kontrolliert vor einem Jahr?
Ja, das ist sehr gut, dass Sie regelmäßig Ihren Hausarzt besuchen.
Und rauben Sie her?
Manchmal.
Was meinen Sie mit manchmal?
Bei einer Feier oder so was, wenn Freunde da sind.
Ich habe keine Schachtel zu Hause.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Was trinken Sie?
Wie häufig?
Ich trinke Bier.
Ab und zu oder jeden Tag?
Jeden Tag ein Feier am Bier.
Nach der Arbeit trinke ich immer ein Bier.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, Herr Vogel.
Nehmen Sie Drogen oder hatten Sie früher einen Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Ich nehme aktuell keine Drogen ein.
Meinen Sie, früher haben Sie probiert?
Ja, da war ich noch jung, da war ich 18 oder 19.
Da hat man schon ein bisschen probiert.
Aber Drogen nehme ich keine ein.
Ich habe sehr starken Schmerzen.
Ich brauche Medikamente.
Ich kann mich auch nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Herr Vogel, ich verstehe Sie, dass es sehr schwer ist.
Wir werden in ein paar Minuten unser Gespräch beenden.
Ich habe eine Erkrankung über Ihre Familie geschichtet.
Ich bitte Sie um Verständnis.
Ich habe eine Erkrankung über Ihre Familie geschaffen.
Meine beiden Eltern sind gestorben.
Ich habe eine Erkrankung über Voranzi gestorben.
Mein Vater hatte einen Leberversagen.
Er hatte ein Problem mit dem Leber.
Meine Mutter ist an Schlaganfall verstorben.
Wann sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater vor 10 Jahren und meine Mutter vor 5 Jahren.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe ein Bruder.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt zu dem.
Ich spaziere.
Ich bin immer in Bewegung.
Ich habe alle meine richtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe noch keine Schmerzen gehabt.
Es kann eventuell Krebs sein.
Herr Vogel, bitte denken Sie nicht am schlimmsten Fall.
Denken Sie bitte positiv.
Es kann auch sein.
Es kann eine Herzinfarkt sein.
Es ist nur ein Verdacht.
Das muss bestätigt werden.
Ich werde Sie sofort für mich untersuchen.
Ich habe einen Herzinfarkt.
Das könnte sein.
Aber mein Herz ist doch da oben, ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, das kann sein, aber manchmal diese Herzschmerzen spürt man im Oberbau.
Es könnte sein, aber das ist nur ein Verdacht, das muss noch bestätigt werden.
Ich werde sie körperlich unterzugen, also ihren Herzabhörern,
ihr Herzabhörern abtastet und ihren Bauch abtastet.
Ich werde auch KG schreiben.
Kann man das dann sehen? Kann man das sehen, wenn ich krebs habe?
Nein, ja, bitte denken Sie nicht am schlimmsten Strafion.
Ja, das kann ...
Ja, weil ich habe Ihnen gesagt, mein Vater ist am Leberversagen verstorben
und wir wissen nicht, ob er krebs hat oder nicht, hat er deswegen wenigstens besorgt.
Ich verstehe Ihre Bedenken.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, Sie sind in guten Händen.
Wir machen alles, damit Sie wieder gesund werden.
Okay, und ich, nach der Untersuchung und operative Diagnostik,
ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt ...
... operative Diagnostik ...
Was ist das?
Ja, wie EKG und Ultraschalluntersuchung des Baus.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Ich werde eine Ultraschall-Konograpie veranlassen.
Muss ich denn hier bleiben im Krankenhaus oder kann ich gleich wieder nach Hause
und auf die Häuschen, die ich hier machen muss?
Nein, Sie müssen hier bleiben.
Ja, wir ...
... die Uzah-Heir-Aberbechwertung, Diagnostik ...
... Diagnostik können.
Sie müssen hier bleiben.
Aber ich muss morgen arbeiten, wahrscheinlich.
Sie können es krank schreiben.
Ja, ich ...
... ich ...
... ich kann es später darüber sprechen.
Okay, okay, dann kriege ich jetzt ein ...
... was geben Sie mir an den Schmerzmedikamenten?
Gibt es eine Tablette oder machen Sie eine Infusion?
Was machen Sie denn?
Wir verwenden eine Infusion-Tablette.
Nicht eine Tablette.
Okay.
Hilft das denn schnell?
Hilft das ...
Ja, ja, das hilft schnell.
Aber Ibuprofen hilft nicht, das sage ich Ihnen schon mal.
Das hat nicht geholfen, Ibuprofen.
Geben Sie was anderes?
Helft ...
... ja ...
... aber zuerst ...
... brauchen wir eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Ja, dann werde ich Ihnen richtige Medikamente ...
Aber ich habe jetzt Schmerzen, ich brauche jetzt Schmerzen Medikamente.
Ich kann doch nicht jetzt noch zwei Stunden warten.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen einen Venetzugang legen.
Ja, ich werde Ihnen eine Schmerzmedikamente geben.
Okay, vielen Dank, das ist der Rat von Ihnen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe einen Kollegen und andere Fragen.
Ich kann nicht ruhig bleiben.
Wenn die Patienten ein bisschen ...
... provozieren ...
... provozieren, kann ich nicht ruhig bleiben und ...
... ja, vielleicht etwas ein bisschen schiefgegangen.
Alles gut.
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Eine Frage, welche Stattung, welche Dosierung ...
... eine Kollegin, aber Sie haben gesagt, der Name ist ...
... Dichwissen und ein Monat.
Danke.
Oder haben Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ich denke, ich habe auch eine Frage.
Genau.
Aber diese Fragen, Felt ...
... die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie ab wieder weg?
Seit 4 Stunden dauert und es wird mehr.
Ja, zu dem Ende und an der Wende.
Sie haben gesagt, seit Beginn ist Herr Schmerzen keine Sturkank, aber ...
... gehen Sie ab?
Ja, habe ich keine Probleme.
Ja, für die ihr müsst, für die Fragen.
Haben Sie öfter aufstoßen?
Ja, seit 4 Stunden auch ein bisschen vermehrt.
Und kommt dabei nur Luft oder auch Säuren?
Nee, nochmal.
Okay, danke.
Also, mein Problem sind die Bauchschmerzen.
Das ist mein Problem im Oberbau.
Aber ich baue Schmerzen, das ist mein Problem.
Ja, danke.
Ja, in der Stärklinie geht von einem Milka-Impfaktus aus.
Aber ja, bis zum Ausfluss hinterfass, ja, besonders hinterfass,
dann können wir vielleicht mal ein Problem ...
Nein, Doktor.
Nein.
Na Tu- tat Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte über einen neuen Patienten berichten darf ich ...
Scheiße los.
ape oscillte.
Ist eine PfeOh 15% japanese.
Er ist eine 54-jährige Patient. Er ist 1,65 m groß und 80 kg, wieg.
Er stellt sich seit 5 Jahren auf den Finale-Skala von 11 bis 10 bei 7 Ligen,
die Schmerzen zahlend stecken und drucken.
Und despite the lack of the patient, über Nausea, ohne vomitus, die Schmerzen würden links und rechts Körper australen.
Die vegetative Anamnese, bis auf Zobrennen,
war die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Anvor Erkrankungen nannte der Patient hypercholesterol.
Er hat eine Cholesterinämie.
Er hat keine Lust mehr oder hat der Hausarzt abgesetzt?
Er hat täglich Feierabend.
Er hat mit Bier geantwortet.
Er ist lebt mit seiner Partnerin.
Er hat eine
Alkoholerkrankung besteht, ob er Alkoholiker ist. Das müssen Sie nachfragen. Das ist wichtig für die Anemese.
Ja, Sie haben total recht. Danke, dass Sie mich bestätigen.
In der Familienanemese ergaben sich leberzirose bei den Partnern.
Leberzirose? Leberzirose, beim Vater, er sei daran gestorben.
Hat sein Vater auch getrunken? Ja, ich musste unbedingt fragen.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Aber in 20 Minuten können wir nicht ausführlich...
Können Sie gleich nachholen? Ja, ich werde Sie nachholen.
Ja, ja.
Apoplex bei der Mutter, die gestorben sei.
Und er habe keine Kinder.
Ja.
Geschwister?
Ja, das war es.
Er hat einen Bruder, er hat keinen Kontakt mit ihm.
Er arbeitet als Maschinenführer in einer Fabrik.
Hat er Stress?
Ja, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Sie haben einiges nicht gefragt? Ja.
Was glauben Sie dem, was er hat?
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
Am Anfang dachte ich, mit diesen fehlenden Fragen,
ein Herzimpakt, aber jetzt habe ich meine Meinung geändert.
Geändert? Okay.
Was glauben Sie, was er hat?
Aber Herzinfarkt war ja schon mal gut.
Müssen Sie auch ausschließen?
Ja, die anonystische Angaben, die anonystische Angaben
sehnten am ersten auf eine gute Fankreatie zu gehen.
Das ist ein Alkoholabosus.
Ein Alkoholabosus, eine Familie.
Noch wichtiger müssen wir auch was machen.
Haben Sie Blutab genommen?
Nehmen Sie Blutab?
Sie nehmen Blutab, ich nehme Blutab.
Welche Werte sind besonders wichtig bei diesen Patienten?
Pankreas und Zümer.
Sie machen Blutbild, BCG, CRP.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass sie mein Herz ausschließen möchten.
Sie machen die mit.
Ihre Diagnose ist schon berechtigt.
Sie haben gesagt, sie haben drückende, technische Schmerzen.
Sie haben gefragt, ob der Geilensteiner hat.
Sie haben auch gefragt, ob der Geilensteiner bekannt hat.
Sie haben gesagt, es ist nicht alles Alkohol, es ist Alkoholbedingte.
Aber es ist die billiere Genese.
Können Sie gleich nachfragen, haben Sie Schmerzmedikamente gegeben?
Ich habe ein Benöseszugang geleckt.
Mit diesem Zugang wurde Analgetica eingeneitet.
Was haben Sie gegeben?
Mit Metamizol.
Es gibt auch Differenzialdiagnosen.
Sie kommen als Differenzialdiagnose in Betra.
Sie haben eine Schmerzmedikamente gegeben.
Sie haben eine Pancreatitis.
Sie haben eine Analyzedicaterapie eingeneitet.
Was ist wichtiger als Antibiose?
Sie wissen nicht, ob es eine billiere Pancreatitis ist.
Sie haben im Labor gesehen, dass es eine hohe Lipase ist.
Sie haben gesehen, dass es eine Pancreatitis ist.
Was geben Sie als Erstes?
Sie haben eine ausreichende Flüssigkeit.
Sie haben eine Flüssigkeit.
Sie haben eine Antibiose.
Sie haben eine Scholastase.
Sie haben eine Bekannte Herzinsuffizienz.
Vielen Dank.